mr vice president
i look out over my biden sign in my
front yard
and i see a sea of drum flags and yard
signs
that's a voter at a joe biden town hall
in pennsylvania last month
raising the topic of lawn signs the
cardboard rectangles may not be a
scientific gauge necessarily of
political support
but they are impossible to ignore giving
both supporters of a candidate and
campaign operatives a sense of optimism
or concern
and as brook silva braga found out the
sign wars have taken a new turn this
year
[Music]
it's hard to say if they prove anything
about the direction of an election
[Music]
[Applause]
just the same as like putting out the
american flag you know showing what side
what side you're on but these october
ornaments
for our divided times i love to decorate
anyway
maybe the simplest most public way to
make a political stand
and i said you know we had a smaller
sign in 2016. it's 2020 we have a big
sign
political yard signs have long dotted
the american landscape
but four years ago something seemed
different
how long have you been into the signs
probably since the 2016 election
a certain anti-establishment campaign
found fertile ground in american lawns
what was the motivation the candidate
the candidate in his story
from jeannie chase's new hampshire yard
to gloria gibert's pennsylvania spread
trump signs bloomed something about
candidate trump
made you want to be public about your
support in a way you hadn't been for
other candidates
a lot of people were getting disgusted
with politicians in general they say one
thing and do another thing
i'm getting goosebumps because this man
i'm telling you we just have a lot of
faith in
him but the carpet of signs from the
master marketer
did not sit well with mark graziadio the
other party gave him out like
like candy he's the democratic chairman
for wayne county in rural northeast
pennsylvania
yes it's a republican stronghold but
grazia dio knew there was another reason
his party got
trounced in the 2016 sign war
even in states like pennsylvania where
trump won the vote by
less than one percent we were unable to
get signs and people wait what does that
mean
unable to get signs the campaign just
wouldn't provide them for us
they thought the signs were a waste of
time um they didn't think that they were
effective
but see where we think they're effective
is not so much in getting people to
change their minds
but to reinforce that there are other
people here who think like you do
if you only see signs for the other
candidate then you may think you're
overwhelmed
jeff eggleston another pennsylvania
democrat
certainly felt overwhelmed last election
night huge news
actually the ap now projecting that
donald trump has won the state of
pennsylvania
i went to bed and my wife you know cried
you know i mean we were
we were devastated and i realized at
that time that i hadn't
done enough so in 2020 rolled around
eggleston whose long-supported
democratic campaigns
decided the contribution he could make
was designing
and printing his own joe biden signs
they did one delivery
around the state how many signs uh 12
000. okay that's a lot of signs that was
a lot you know i was
i was doing cartwheels down the street i
was telling everybody i delivered 12 000
signs you know
before you knew it all these people saw
him and said hey i want those signs
and so then we did an order for 30 000.
then we did an order for 40 000 and then
we did another order for 20 000. who's
we
um well me and that was how jeff
eggleston
came to drive 4 000 miles across
pennsylvania
and delivered nearly 150 000 joe biden
signs
defying his party's conventional wisdom
from my
experience it started with the obama
campaign and it became like a dogma
within the campaign
community that you just don't deal with
it at all
why the democratic party can be very
cerebral
we've done studies that show if you call
somebody this percentage of the time you
can sway them
when someone puts a yard sign in the
yard it's really hard for us to quantify
what the effect is
that that has on people so do they prove
anything about the direction of an
election
columbia university professor donald
green is one of the few
to seriously research the answer we
found an average effect of about a
1.7 percentage point boost so
a candidate who would ordinarily get
48.3 would get 50.0
in a close race that could make the
difference
but the research tracked small local
elections
green hasn't studied the impact on
presidential races
because of a legal obstacle we have a
bit of a difficulty where we can't use
university funds to buy lawn signs you
would need someone to donate the signs
that's right getting to the bottom of
this is something we certainly can do
for now the best evidence of at least
their psychological impact
may be how opponents treat them
vandalism has become a bipartisan vice
which only makes the wagner floyd
household
that much more remarkable all our
neighbors think we're crazy
yeah they don't understand it joe wagner
and megan floyd are lifelong best
friends
and co-owners of this house in johnstown
pennsylvania
with a conspicuously divided front yard
so where are we now with the signs we
got three each right three
been matching each other sign for sign
for months
and yet somehow have not let the names
on the cardboard
come between them i actually fixed the
one too because yeah
it didn't fix my one bottom side inside
and what does that feel like isn't that
just totally going against what you're
trying to do
i felt like such a traitor i'm just
kidding
you know she has her her views and i
have my views and
we can try to agree to disagree
lawn signs do not tell us who will win
tuesday
but they do prove something important
about the election
i'm just pushing for a brighter future
as the sign says
support for the political process itself
that's their choice just like i'm having
my choice
for cbs this morning saturday brook
silva braga in wayne county pennsylvania
i love that couple i love everything
about that couple the fact that they can
still get along and yet have such
disparate points of view but here's the
bottom line with with lawn science you
leave nothing on the table in a campaign
and if you have the money you know you
need to spend the money and i think that
a few elections ago you know folks
thought the money should go elsewhere
it's a reminder it just stands out in
your mind i don't
impact it has but it's there yeah it's
still nice that joe helped megan
it is